[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute geht es nach ganz langer zeit
endlich mal wieder ein baustellen update
ich glaube es gab noch nie so viele
kommentare sally zeigt mal wieder euer
haus das problem war einfach wir konnten
jetzt die letzten drei monate nicht auf
der baustelle filmen weil zum einen wir
wenig zeit hatten das heißt ich aber
zwei bücher geschrieben einmal das
türkische kochbuch und das kinderbuch
dann waren wir viel auf messen unterwegs
dann hatten wir auch urlaub und während
im urlaub ich auch hier eigentlich gar
nichts passiert denn auch die handwerker
haben ja über den sommer hin urlaub und
ja deswegen haben ein bisschen
verzögerungen gehabt jetzt ist natürlich
auch ein bisschen was passiert ich
glaube beim letzten mal habe ich oben
gerade noch die mauern gemacht und jetzt
zeige ich euch einfach mal wie weit wir
sind was demnächst ansteht was wir
momentan machen mein bruder mein papa
die sind auch gerade im hintergrund
beschäftigt und ja wir laufen jetzt
einfach mal kurz durchs haus hier auf
dem boden seht ihr jetzt auch schon ein
paar rohre wir haben jetzt hier die
abwasserleitungen schon legen und ein
paar belüftungsrohre und wir versuchen
natürlich so viel wie möglich auf der
baustelle selber zu machen also das was
man eben selber machen kann
so kann man nämlich am meisten geld
sparen und ja hier werden jetzt gerade
die rohre gelegt ich glaube es dauert
auch noch ein bisschen und hier im
hintergrund zum beispiel habe ich heute
morgen schon mit meinem bruder
angefangen
wir haben hier die abwasserrohre gelegt
aber nicht fürs abwasser sondern für
unsere zentrale staubsauger anlage die
wir jetzt hier ins haus bekommen und das
machen wir auch gleich fertig sobald
sich mit dem videodreh fertig bin und
das ist eine richtig geniale sache aber
da mache ich einfach separat mal ein
video dazu das ist wirklich super vor
allem für alle die einfach ein bisschen
einfacher zu hause sagen wollen
und ja für murat natürlich möchte ich
auch schon drauf
wahnsinn
hier sind wir jetzt gerade in unserem
küchenbereich das heißt er wird später
unsere youtube küche seien hier auch der
esstisch die im hintergrund der moral
und mein bruder und mein papa die
zeichnungen gerade was zeichnet ihr an
ok also die zeit gerade an wo eben die
ganzen ältere elektrogeräte hinkommen
also herd kühlschrank und so weiter
damit mein bruder einfach die leitungen
legen kann und wir zeigen euch in der
zwischenzeit schon mal alles weitere
also hier liegt jetzt momentan alles
herum aber sehr ordentlich muss ich
sagen und wenn man dann hier durch läuft
dann haben wir hier rechts und links die
toiletten und hier sieht man jetzt zum
beispiel ganz gut die lüftungsrohre und
wir haben an der b und entlüftungsanlage
und das müsst ihr euch so vorstellen wie
es zwei schlafen zb nachts immer mit
offenem fenster weil ich einfach bei
sauberer und frischer luft viel besser
schlafen kann ich krieg da noch keine
kopfschmerzen zum beispiel und demnächst
brauchen wir das gar nicht mehr also wir
müssen das fenster nicht mehr offen
lassen sondern die luft ist immer ein
zuhause das wird immer schön sauber
gemacht eben durch die be- und
entlüftungsanlage hat den vorteil dass
wenn zum beispiel ein kind war uns im
zimmer schläft so wie er momentan dann
schimpfte murat immer wenn ich es
fenster nachts offen lasse weil es
einfach viel zu kalt wird und weil die
kleine dann ständig krank wird weil sie
sich eben nicht zu deckt ja das problem
haben wir dann bald nicht mehr
samira ist hier gerade denn von der
herrentoilette auch die damentoilette
und wir gehen mal weiter ins lager und
hier seht ihr einfach überall wie gesagt
die rache das ist für die
elektroleitungen auf dem boden die
belüftungsrohre die abwasserrohre die
wasserrohre und hier haben wir auch
schon teilweise die fenster drin also
die wurden jetzt bereits schon geliefert
und ja da haben uns einfach für fenster
entschieden die anthrazit innen und
außen und unten feststehen damit wir zum
beispiel auch mal ein schreibtisch da
vorstellen können und dass es einfach
nicht beeinträchtigt wird
und oben kommen die fenster dann
trotzdem schön öffnen
also hier sind jetzt gerade in unserem
lager da wird dann alles gelagert was
eben hinten alles anfängt und hier oben
sieht man zum beispiel auch die anlage
die ab und zu luft anlage und es ist
auch wirklich unkontrolliertes belüften
das heißt es passiert dann nicht mehr
dass die wohnung zum beispiel unterkühlt
da muss man sie wieder aufheizen
das hat man einfach alles nicht mehr
hier auf dem boden kommen später eben
auch die restlichen horde hin und dann
kommt eben nochmal der fußboden drauf so
etwas 17 zentimeter und ja wird alles
hoffe ich ziemlich schön und samira ist
die luft rein kommt scheint euch hier
sind wir jetzt gerade in unserer garage
und hier werden wir auch ganz ganz viele
vorbereitungen treffen und zwar kommt
zum beispiel im super charger rein das
heißt für elektroautos wir haben zwar
momentan kein elektroauto aber momentan
in den medien ist es auch wirklich ein
ganz ganz großes thema und ich denke
wenn wir das ganze vorbereitet haben und
hier auf eine steckdose haben für
elektroautos dann können wir uns zum
beispiel in ein oder zwei jahren auch
ein elektroauto kaufen
ich denke das wird auch immer mehr im
kommen seien und wie ihr vielleicht
mitbekommen habt verbrennen wir hier in
unserem haus dann später auch kein öl
oder kein gas das brauchen wir alles
nicht denn wir erzeugen unseren strom
einfach selber durch die
photovoltaikanlage und die wärmepumpe
und es ist natürlich richtig schön
umwelt schonen und das finde ich richtig
gut aber jetzt gehen wir weiter von der
garage ich zeige ich mich im hintergrund
den technikraum zweitschlüssel
abgeschlossen sind doch nur wer hier
sehr wahrscheinlich
ich hoffe wir kommen jetzt rein super
dass du den schlüssel nicht verloren
habe ich natürlich ausnahmen semira guck
mal was es hier zu entdecken gibt ok
während samira hier noch weiter auf
entdeckungstour geht gleich euch jemals
im technikraum und zwar kommt hier
später alles rein also das ist sozusagen
das gehirn unseres hauses
hier kommt eine bwt anlage rein also
eine wasserenthärtungsanlage hier kommt
unser zentralen stabs und die
zentralstaat förderanlage rein
hier kommen die elektro kästen rhein ein
bussystem für unser smart home also
alles wird eine praktisch zentral von
hier gesteuert und ist hier schön hinter
dem haus verstaut ja jetzt im moment ist
so eine kleine grimm bekomme also hier
verstauen jetzt auch die handwerker
natürlich alles weil man eben den raum
abschließen kann
hier sind wir jetzt gerade in unserem
eingang da fehlt jetzt noch die
wohnungstür und wir wissen jetzt noch
nicht ob wir ja mal eine wohnungstür
haben werden mit schlüssel oder mit
fingerprint oder mit zu kleinen bobby
das wissen wir alles noch nicht da sind
wir gerade noch am herum diskutieren mit
murat und diana ist immer vom urlaub
gekommen und haben dann gesehen dass
hier statt einer wohnungseingangstür ein
fenster drin war
ich wollte ich mal einen baustellen
abheben also es ist es kein spaß
ich war jetzt zwei tage in salzburg und
ich habe sich zwei tage jetzt nicht auf
der baustelle und die tänze sind
gekommen und das ist normalerweise der
eingangstür die haben wirklich das
geschafft ein fenster in die eingangstür
einzubauen
das wären zwei tage nicht da bist dann
passiert sowas also es ist echt wahnsinn
das ist das ist der eingang
sie haben ein fenster eingebaut
jungs das ist eine tür nichts nichts
nichts die fenster das ist doch eine tür
ein
[Musik]
schaut man sich außer der weihnachtsmann
meinte clay durchs fenster nix
weihnachtsmann
ich wollte mich gerade für apple
das ist ein fenster das ist das gibt's
doch gar nicht können da vielleicht eine
tür einbauen als fenster zur folge hätte
sich nicht steigt jetzt ja in
deutschland generieren
das muss die tür seine jungs baut das
ding aus das muss die tür sein da wo
hier rein gekommen sein da ist ein
fenster und das ist eine tür bietet das
sofort ändern
ich muss mich fragen ich dreh
gleichgewicht es gibt es nicht also ich
werde morgen mit dem baustellen update
bin dass wieder eine tür ist wir hören
uns bis dahin tschüss
hier sind wir jetzt in unserem
wohnzimmer und da wollte ich euch mal
die fenster zeigen
hier haben wir zum beispiel das ist
unsere eigene schuld haben ein falsches
fenster bestellt und zwar wollte ich hin
feststehen das element was man gar nicht
aufmachen muss den weg kommt später nur
ein esstisch in und ich wollte praktisch
nur was zum rausgucken haben
das werden wir denke ich noch
austauschen lassen und das fenster oben
dann einbauen denn da fehlt noch so ein
dreh kipp fenster aber so etwas passiert
halt und es ist einfach so wenn viele
firmen zusammenarbeiten müssen und man
einfach an zu viel denken muss dann kann
es einfach passieren dass man kleine
fehler passieren
so wie hier vorne zum beispiel hier sind
die fenster auch schon eingebaut aber
die scheiben fädeln und zwar weil sie
bei der lieferung kaputt gegangen sind
also wirklich eins zwei drei vier
scheiben sind kaputt gegangen
jetzt sind die rahmen drin und jetzt
müssen wir einfach noch mal auf die
lieferung der fenster arten quatschkopf
[Musik]
kaum quatschkopf können wir zeigen mal
unseren zuschauern den garten denn wir
bald haben werden
und da draußen da haben wir bald unseren
garten das hier ist eigentlich für uns
bedrohen aber vielleicht kann ich damit
den murat steuern kommen wir probieren
es mal wieso renten der durch den garten
und und und
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
du musst den münzen sammeln sprung
entspringen strengen
und jetzt höhere lohnansprüche level
vorbei kommt weiter geht
hier sind sie jetzt im eingang meiner
eltern und hier rechts von mir links von
euch seht ihr den aufzugsschacht da hat
sich jetzt noch nicht so viel getan
da müssen wir jetzt einfach noch ein
bisschen warten
und den macht übrigens der mann von
einer zuschauerin von mir genauso wie
die wasserinstallation ja das sind halt
zufälle also der wald auf der baustelle
angefangen zu arbeiten
und irgendwann kommen sie dann darauf
acht gott meine frau die guckt er die
sally die stimme kommt mir bekannt vor
ja und da müssen wir auf dem bau immer
fotos machen für die ehefrauen und dann
schicke ich immer ein bisschen was mit
und dann ist es natürlich okay jetzt
können wir mal hochgehen zu meinen
eltern und auch in unseren bereich denn
drüben haben wir noch keine treppe das
heißt momentan nutzen wir einfach noch
die betontreppe von meinen eltern
und wie gesagt ein fahrstuhl haben wir
halt einfach da damit meine eltern wenn
sie mal schwere sachen eingekauft haben
damit sie das eben ins erste
obergeschoss transportieren können oder
gott bewahre aber wenn sie mal später
zum beispiel im rollstuhl wären oder so
also da haben wir schon darauf geachtet
dass die wohnung alters und
behindertengerecht gebaut ist und
deswegen auf jeden fall der fahrstuhl
also das ist sehr sinnvoll
jetzt gehen wir mal nach oben und
schauen wie weit die jungs oben sind
morath und mein papa und mein bruder
die waren oben jetzt die ganze zeit
beschäftigt geht einfach mal mit ich hab
den aufzug benutzen auch ein paar mal
hier kann man zum beispiel ganz gut
sehen meine eltern die bekommen weiße
fenster also diesen außen antrag sich in
weiß und zwar aus dem grund meine mama
die kann mit anthrazitfarbenen fenstern
glaube ich nicht so viel anfangen
die möchte lieber eine helle wohnung
weise fenster und ya konan sich mit dem
dunklen einfach nicht so anfreunden
aber bei uns passt ganz zukunft rein und
ich freue mich auch echt schon auf die
dunklen fenster und jetzt gucken wir mal
bei meinen 11
einfach rein hier seht ihr zum beispiel
dass die tür breiter ist das heißt auch
hier haben wir einfach darauf geachtet
dass die wohnung altersgerecht und
behindertengerecht ist damit man eben
auch mal mit einem rollstuhl oder einem
rollator einfach schön bequem auch rein
fahren kann
hier haben wir so eine kleine vertiefung
in der wand da bekommen sie später eine
garderobe das heißt die garderobe
befindet sich dann direkt hinter der
eingangstür
dann können sie gleich alles hinhängen
und ablegen und hier rechts haben wir
das badezimmer und es hat etwa zehn
quadratmeter das heißt das ist eine
perfekte größe für meine eltern hier
kommt eine badewanne eine begehbare
dusche alles natürlich auch wieder
altersgerecht und ja die größe reicht
auf jeden fall für beide aus hier kommt
dann so eine teillösung rein damit immer
eben auf engstem raum wirklich auch ganz
viel verstauen kann
apropos verstauen diese ganzen rohre
hier dem mein bruder installiert hat
müssen auch verstaut werden
aber das kriegen wir ganz locker hin
dass ihnen nur ungefähr 64
irgendwie können wir die bestimmt
irgendwo verstecken
warum 64
[Musik]
hier seht ihr zum beispiel auch die
verteiler und auch die belüftungs und
entlüftungsrohr von meinen eltern das
heißt bei denen wird eigentlich das
meiste hier im lager in der
vorratskammer gesammelt und eben auch
schön versteckt stark hatte murat dran
vorbei morath
hier sehen wir zum beispiel im
schlafzimmer meiner eltern und hier
hinter mir das fenster das muss jetzt
auch wieder getauscht werden
weil es beim transport gebrochen ist
also wir sind echt mit all unseren
handwerkern zufrieden die arbeiten alle
echt super und wirklich auch sehr sauber
aber so transportschäden die kommen halt
mal vor und das ist auch gar nicht
schlimm muss man halt immer zeitlich ein
bisschen einkalkulieren
und deswegen wird deshalb noch getauscht
und die anderen fenster und deswegen hat
sich das auch ein bisschen verzögert
aber wie gesagt ist nicht schlimm
den puffer hatten wir eingeplant zwar
nicht so viel aber naja wird auch
getauscht und dann wird es auch alles
ganz schön so kommt herein
wir sind doch keine schreiben aber egal
ich wollte einfach das fenster öffnen ja
kommt herein
hier sind wir jetzt eben wohn essbereich
meiner eltern ich hier hinter mir die
küche hier hinter euch das wohnzimmer
viel sieht man noch nicht oder fußboden
sieht auch ein bisschen leer aus als ein
paar chores und zwar verlegt aber ich
denke spätestens nächste woche ist ja
der komplette fußboden voll mit
heizungsrohren mit abwasser mit dem
belüftungsrohre usw
das heißt da wird man dann
wahrscheinlich kaum noch was vom
fußboden sehen und da kommt er dann
später aber dann noch der estrich drüber
unter fußbodenbelag und da kommen wie
gesagt sei 17 zentimeter noch drauf
ja nun geht's weiter asche schon wieder
los angeles zieht voll c3 weiß er dass
keine scheibe wird gesteckt ich weiß es
nicht
hier sind wir in unserem zukünftigen
familienbad hier sind jetzt auch schon
einige rohre verlegt worden
und hier sieht man zum beispiel dass die
kernbohrung hier falsch gemacht wurde
das heißt das loch hier entstand über
die alten pläne aber ich finde gar nicht
schlimm dass kam er später als guckloch
benutzen morath
da kannst du da unten stehen und ich sag
dann hallo hat nur blöd wäre natürlich
hier die toilette landeten alles runter
läuft ja wohl schon jetzt sicher weg ja
bei euch sieht es jetzt wahrscheinlich
alles so mega groß aus aber so groß ist
das gar nicht ihr müsst euch vorstellen
da kommen wir als vierköpfige familie
mit rein meine eltern wohnen hier und
natürlich arbeiten wir auch hier uns
arbeiten dann ungefähr etwa zehn man
hier bei uns vor ort also meinen sally
team und ja was passiert jetzt demnächst
momentan sieht man nicht so viel aber
jetzt passiert gerade ganz viel das
heißt in den nächsten wochen wird man
das auch optisch sehen höher auf murat
und hier wird wirklich ganz viel
passieren wir sind gerade so am
feintuning sozusagen
wir planen gerade unsere steckdosen zum
beispiel das badezimmer haben wir jetzt
fertig geplant die küche wird übermorgen
komplett fertig geplant also wirklich
ich weiß dann wo welche schublade
hinkommt wo welche steckdose hinkommt
und in der nächsten zeit wird hier auch
alles wirklich eingebaut
ich hoffe dass wir bis vier einziehen
können also das war so mein wunschtermin
dieses jahr schaffen wir leider nicht
mehr
es ist einfach ein bisschen zu viel
dazwischen gekommen aber ist gar nicht
schlimm hauptsache es wird schön und
hauptsache es wird alles gut gebaut ja
ich denke unser haus wird eines der
innovativsten aber auch eines der
nachhaltigsten häuser deutschlandweit
werden
irgend könnt dann wirklich sehen was man
alles mit smarthome machen kann und was
man alles auch überhaupt mit technik
anstellen kann ohne dass es aber zu viel
schnickschnack wird also alles was wir
einbauen ist wirklich sehr sinnvoll und
nicht einfach nur irgendeine spielerei
mein nächstes update wird dann
wahrscheinlich über den zentralen über
die zentrale staubsauger anlage gehen da
zeige ich euch wie wir die hier einbauen
und wenn man die benutzt
wird es auch am ende später aussehen
wird und ich hoffe euch hat dieses
wieder gefallen und wir sehen uns dann
beim nächsten mal wieder zwischendurch
kommen natürlich ganz üblich wie immer
meine rezepte und dann folgt schon ganz
bald mein nächstes update also bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss
wir sind jetzt auf der baustelle und
jetzt gebe ich meine bürger ab der der
burger partie
das habe ich so tief fleischwolf
durchgemacht rindfleisch durch
fleischtöpfen habe ich ein peppiger
[Musik]
also schmeckt gut härtetest bestanden
und ja ich lasse die männer jetzt in
ruhe essen und damit arbeiten und wir
sehen das nächste mal ziehen
[Applaus]